continue bringing on all the romance for
this valentine's day
there's no better way to do that than
with some delicious homemade chocolate
chip cookie dough
fudge smith's jeff excuse me smith's
chef
jeff jackson shows us how and hello
everybody i'm chef jeff from smith's
valentine's day is coming up
you could treat your sweetheart to a
night out on the town some dinner maybe
some flowers and maybe some candy or
you can make them something homemade and
they'll love it i'm going to show you
how to make a chocolate chip cookie
dough fudge that requires no cooking
it's going to be super easy although i
would say we're going to be using
raw flour in this recipe so a good tip
to take away that raw flour taste is to
throw it in the oven 350 for about 15
minutes just the flour
and then it kind of takes that away so
let's get right into it so what i have
in is some brown sugar i'm going to put
in a bowl with some
softened butter that i have right here
and then we're going to
throw also some salt and some vanilla
and i'm going to use my mixer so pardon
the noise that i'm going to be making
here in just a second
but we just want to cream these together
really quickly it doesn't take very long
just to get them to come together
it doesn't take too much once they've
come together like they have here
should be almost like a sand consistency
sort of i would say what i'm going to do
next is
not chocolate chips yet we're going to
get that flour in there so all of it
throw it right in there
and give that a mix so it's almost like
we're making
cookie dough but without eggs or any of
those other things
let's just get this mixed together
looks perfect so it should look like
brown sand again like i said before
go ahead and make a mess it's all right
too so i'm going to do now is fold in my
chocolate chips just
use a spoon to stir those in in fact i'm
going to be
done with the mixer so give those a stir
the next thing we're going to do is i
have some
white chocolate chips that i've melted
so i just got to give that a stir as you
can see
some white chocolate chips just throw in
the microwave for a little bit
and then i have some sweetened condensed
milk this is what it's going to bring
all this fudge together
and get that in there you can find that
on the baking aisle at your local smiths
let me give that a stir and then once
that's
there i'm going to get it in my bowl
and you can see just how easy this
recipe is
bring it together and then right there i
have a nine by
nine uh cat or a baking dish and i've
sprayed it with the non-kick
nonstick cooking spray and then i'm just
gonna get this all
to come together like so and then i'm
gonna get it inside my
i also have parchment paper in there as
you can see okay
you can see it's not quite come together
yet but that's okay just get your hands
in there like so
press it down and then you're gonna get
it in the fridge and then what you're
left with
is this awesome looking fudge and it
comes right out
look at how awesome that is let me move
this out of the way so you can see
so it just comes out beautifully put a
little bit of extra chocolate chips on
top
let's go ahead and let's cut these up
and it should just cut
nice and beautifully
and you've got homemade that you made
chocolate chip cookie dough fudge it's
so good
your significant other is going to love
it happy valentine's day you can find
all these ingredients your local smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we'll see you next time
bye that looks delicious to get the
recipe and for more information
visit smithsfoodanddrug.com mercedes